gérard longuet est l'invité de preuves
par 3 ce soir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous on va parler aujourd'hui
compétitivité et cacophonie aujourd'hui
sur les 35 heures on va parler bien sûr
c'est la compétition interne à l'ump et
des appels à manifester de jean françois
copé
samir tounzi de la fp viendra vous
demandez sur ce plateau si vous êtes
prêts à descendre vous aussi dans la rue
et puis est-ce que ce qui ma politique
favorise sénat les affaires de la droite
qui ne perd pas de vue l'objectif 2014
c'est-à-dire reprendre le sénat mais
qu'est la messe de public sénat vous
interrogera sur ce sujet mais pour
commencer gérard longuet la durée légale
du travail ne changera jamais tant que
la gauche sera au pouvoir c'est la
déclaration cet après midi de jean marc
ayrault à l'assemblée nationale il a
tenté d'éteindre l'incendié qu'il avait
lui même allumé le matin dans le
parisien sur les 35 heures est ce que la
polémique est close ce soit un
gouvernement qui est coutumier du fait
en général c'est un autre ministre qui
dément et ministres précédents
aujourd'hui comme des héros qui avait
ouvert la porte de la remise en cause
des 35 heures c'est héros qui découvrant
sa maladresse vis-à-vis de son camp a
fermé la porte des 35 heures je le
regrette je le regrette parce que c'est
la question majeure de la compétitivité
de notre pays c'est la durée globale du
travail
j'en souffre j'en souffre parce que je
considère en effet que nous avons traité
les 35 heures par l'extérieur à travers
les heures supplémentaires ce qui était
pour le pouvoir d'achat des salariés une
bonne affaire mais nous ne sommes pas
rentrés dans le coeur du sujet et le
coeur du sujet c'est que à salariés
allemands en moyenne travaillent 150 à
170 heures de plus qu'un salarié
français et ça c'était car là il pèse
terriblement sur notre compétitivité on
va en parler dans quelques instants
mais autour de cette affaire des 35
heures de jean marc ayrault est ce que
ça pose de globalement le problème de la
crédibilité du premier ministre ou tout
simplement le problème du cap de
l'action gouvernementale
je crois que
c'est connu les gouvernements au siècle
précédent et ce qui a changé c'est
l'extrême réactivité de l'opinion
sollicité par une offre médiatique
considérable depuis naturellement les
chaînes de télévision les radios
internet s'est immédiatement relayée et
amplifiée et il faut que chaque homme
politique est une responsabilité j'en ai
exercé il n'y a pas si longtemps que
cela doit avoir l'idée qu'il est dans un
baquet de formule 1 est que lorsqu on
effleure l'accélérateur le risque de
tête à queue et presqu'îles médiation
maîtrise pas tout or très souvent ce
ministre là mais nous nous sommes
trompés nous aussi mais cela presque
systématiquement se trompent tous dans
le dosage de la communication il parle
pas du tout il a été président de groupe
je l'étais aussi aussi au sénat c'est
entre ce conseil est très importante
mais on n'a pas l'extrême pression des
médias
lorsque vous êtes premier ministre j'ai
vu de très près et edouard balladur par
exemple j'ai vu de très près françois
fillon la moindre réaction la moindre le
moindre mouvement de sourcil en réponse
à une question peut être interprétée et
avoir des conséquences hier sur la
valeur du franc
aujourd'hui sur les taux d'intérêt à
court terme c'est quoi c'est une gamme
de premier ministre la malterie
profondément que c'est un manque de
dévaluation exacte des conséquences des
comportements et d'expression nous un
ministre aujourd'hui à porter le premier
ministre voit ce qu'on lui dit on n'a
plus le droit de réfléchir publiquement
il est là pour énoncer des certitudes
qu'il a assumée qui l'a préparé mais il
n'a pas d'états d'âme à avoir il ya une
formule d'ailleurs que je condamne
complètement pour un ministre à titre
personnel je pense que ça n'existe pas
ou bien la formule nous pourrions
réfléchir à réfléchir c'est le rôle du
parlement un rapporteur dans une
commission un président en commission au
sénat ou à l'assemblée a le droit de
réfléchir un ministre en gaz l'action
collective du gouvernement et donc toute
phrase est une phrase de la décision et
non pas une phrase de la réflexion du
coup j'ai remarqué on parle trop alors
il s'expose trop en l'occurrence il
s'est trop exposé je le pense sur ce
point je ne dis pas qu'il a tort car je
souhaite qu'on ouvre le débat sur les 39
heures nécessaires mais lui était à mon
avis d'imposition de le faire par son
statut de premier ministre alors il
s'expose trop au risque de fragiliser le
présent d'un public s'il lui sert près
de boucliers oui mais ça fait bien
longtemps que les premiers ministres ne
sert plus de bouclier au président de la
république depuis le quinquennat car
depuis le quinquennat et nicolas sarkozy
en avait fait en quelque sorte son acte
de foi
le président est en première ligne dans
cette allée de monter en première ligne
notamment pour faire des propos il y
sera contraint alors on valoir notamment
sur la compétitivité
parce que la force du premier ministre
du septennat
c'était qu'il conduisait une bataille
législative et il était jugé au succès
ou à l'échec des jce est il exactement
tout compris françois là on est
intervenu hier sur la compétitivité il a
dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de sotte mais
un pacte de compétitivité et des mesures
vont être prises au mois de novembre
elles s'étaleront dans le temps pour
éviter tout choc à l'économie française
qui est déjà fragile
c'est une erreur c'est une erreur je
suis tout à fait pour les chiens qui je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que la
france est jugée comme tous les pays du
monde d'ailleurs par ceux qui ayant des
liquidités veulent les placer sur un
pays en espérant que ce pays réussisse
si vous l'annoncer une intention forte
même si les résultats ne sont pas encore
dans les fêtes vous rassurer ceux qui
ont envie d'investir ce qu'ils ont envie
de vous faire confiance
en annonçant les mesures fortes et
naturellement en mettant en oeuvre celle
que vous pouvez tout de suite mettre en
oeuvre vous vous donnez un ballon
d'oxygène à votre pays en diluant comme
le petit poucet cailloux par cailloux
vous donner le sentiment de ne pas y
croire
et vous n'avez pas ce choc de confiance
que pour elle aurait pu créer par
exemple le rapport gallois que j'ai
a souri comme la presse en gallo c'est
une vraie révolution
six pays dans le land présenté le
rapport aux gallois les analystes
extérieur par les français les zones
lice extérieure et ceux qui ont de
l'argent
je vais en chercher dans ma poche les
placerait sur la france en dix ans mais
vous voilà un cheval qui va gagner la
course en en espaçant vous décourager
ceux qui veulent investir tout à fait de
même nature attali a annoncé toute une
série de mesures
trois quarts d'entre elles ont été
adoptées et ils mentent adopter
certaines symbolique comme les taxis
nantais n'ont pas abouti attali n'avait
pas traité de la durée du travail ce qui
à mon avis une erreur
à ma connaissance à ma connaissance mais
toute une série de mesures notamment sur
les professions réglementées sur la
libéralisation de l'activité économique
ont été adoptées dans le sillage du
rapport attali attali était peut-être
plus exhaustif avec moins de locomotive
de décision le problème des rapports qui
sont extérieurs à la majorité à
l'exécutif et qui sont forcément
critiqué par des députés des
parlementaires qui ne sont pas contents
d'avoir elle avait fait en 58 avec oran
avec armand et rue f
et ça a été très très bien être elle est
acceptée parce que ce rapport avait
accompagné une dévaluation et donc
chacun avait compris la fois qu'il y
avait qu'une dévaluation aujourd'hui
impossible pour relancer l'économie et
des mesures de libéralisation que la
france attendait depuis très longtemps
alors vous avez dit quelque chose de
très juste les parlementaires n'aime pas
être dessaisie du devoir de la
responsabilité de proposer un grand
confort même chose pour grenelle de
l'environnement général et en disant
nous sommes capables de faire un certain
nombre de choses je pense que l'erreur
du gouvernement précédent que j'ai
soutenu et l'erreur de ce gouvernement
est de ne pas s'appuyer ainsi assez sur
le travail parlementaire et au parlement
assemblée sénat
des gens compétents pour variable ne pas
les mettre en face d'eux
responsabilités plutôt que d'en faire
des chambres d'enregistrement bouillonne
sur les patrons lorsqu ils font des
propositions lorsqu'il pose même un
ultimatum au gouvernement sur la
compétitivité
là ils sont plutôt dans un rôle
politique et le leur aussi chiant je
vous dire la compétence n'est jamais
inutile même en politique il se trouve
que pour parler médecine et médecins
sont pas inutiles et pour parler
d'économie les chefs d'entreprise ne
sont pas inutiles maintenant
d'entreprise on les a pas entendus quand
les gouvernements les cds filer les
déficits
le parce que les chefs d'entreprise
comme les médecins comme les
intellectuels ou comme je ne sais pas
les maréchaux-ferrants non pas la
responsabilité du pays tout entier
la noblesse du gouvernement et j'ajoute
des parlementaires s'étaient longtemps à
répondre du pays tout entier et donc
lorsqu'ils font plaisir aux uns ils
doivent avoir le souci de ne prendre en
considération la situation des autres
par exemple lorsque les celles
d'entreprises de 10 allégeant les
charges sociales
ok pourquoi pas mais nous avons nous le
devoir de savoir comment la dépense
sociale nécessaire sera financé le chef
d'entreprise c'est pas son problème
pas vraiment milliards aux entrevues
voilà qui va payer cette rentrée voit là
et nous avons nous parlementaires de
droite ou de gauche nous avons le devoir
du collectif de la réflexion globale
c'est pour ça que nous sommes des
parlementaires nationaux et pas
simplement des lobbystes d'intérêt
difficile entre les patrons et le
gouvernement en ce moment ça vous
inquiète
oui parce que les patrons ont un
avantage sur les hommes politiques qui
va peut-être vous surprendre
c'est qu'ils ont pour les plus grands
d'entre eux naturellement la dimension
internationale et ceux dont la france
souffre c'est qu'elle regarde son
nombril et qu'elle ne regarde pas assez
ses voisins et laurence parisot avait
parlé de racisme anti entreprise vous
iriez jusqu'à la jeu de mots ce qui
n'appartiennent pas mon langage
est-ce qu'il faut relever la tva sur les
restaurants le deal disons qu'on
l'achève péril
rétrospectivement ce n'est sans doute
pas prioritaire
pourtant les engagements qui avaient été
pris par la profession
à bord de sa recette avec la discuter
c'est vrai aussi c'est que lorsque la
profession a pris les engagements la
crise économique la régression de 2 % en
2009 la stagnation à la toute petite
croissance de 2010 11 n'était pas non
plus prévu et d'autre part les chefs
d'entreprise du reste la restauration
tellement d'autres soucis à la
réglementation sociale ou à la
réglementation technique qu'ils ont sans
doute biaisée pour essayer de sauver
leur entreprise ce qui est le premier
rôle d'un patron c'était une erreur
c'était un engagement qu'il avait pris à
la lumière de la situation d'avant 2008
peut-être avons-nous manqué de faire de
l'automne 2008
une rupture potable jean françois copé
on en arrive à l'ump multiplie les
propositions chocs pour emporter
il appelle les français inquiets à
descendre dans la rue à manifester sans
quoi pardon inquiet de mesure il n'a pas
précisé inquiète de certaines mesures
que pourrait prendre le gouvernement est
ce que jean françois copé sens de la
limite du débat démocratique
le drone le droit à manifester est un
droit reconnu par la loi
simplement d'abord il doit se faire au
parlement il de faire sur des sanctions
et je voudrais rappeler que la grande
manifestation à laquelle il faisait
référence celle de 1984 sur les collines
c'est une manifestation qui est venue
des écoles elle même elle n'est pas
venue les partis politiques
les grandes manifestations agricoles
sont venues de la fnra ne sont pas nés
les partis politiques les partis
politiques dans notre pays à l'exception
des grands rendez-vous que sont les
présidentielle mobilise rarement des
dizaines de milliers
deux militants d'adhérents de passionnés
je crois que jean françois copé était à
mon avis pas pas le sait pas sa
meilleure inspiration il a raison de
parler d'une inquiétude mais c'est sur
des sujets de société
le mariage des sujets de société la
nationalité nationalité c'est du droit
on peut dire si les parties de les
marier supporter le mariage c'est une
affaire pour tous ça veut dire quoi
non le mariage le mariage reste limitée
n'est pas pour tous mais ce mariage
cette conception du mariage qui au fond
repose sur le refus de la différence
sexuelle l'homme la femme
c'est un débat qui concerne d'abord les
convictions intimes de chacun
il trouve que le droit civil les a
entérinées
je pense que ceux qui s'expriment
aujourd'hui avec le plus de force se
font ceux qui depuis plusieurs
millénaires
je pense au grand rabbin gilles bernheim
ou bien aux évêques de france qui depuis
plusieurs millénaires ont réfléchi à ces
questions alors nous avons des
associations qui disent qu'ils défendent
la théorie du genre que je connais bien
mais qui est relative qui à 50 ans
d'existence c'est plutôt à ces
associations de le porter de l'expliquer
et aux partis politiques de rappeler que
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est
politiquement majoritaire que l'on doit
méprisé des convictions de fond qui se
rattachent à des valeurs permanentes
d'ailleurs savez laignel avait été en
son temps à juste titre dénoncer parce
qu'il avait eu cette formule
invraisemblable vous avez juridiquement
tort parce que vous êtes politiquement
minoritaire est ce que jean françois
copé dénonce il a pas tout à fait tort
c'est d une force gouvernementale qui
voudraient imposer par le bénéfice d'une
majorité
une décision qui en profondeur choc
ceux qui ont réfléchi sur le sujet et
qui sont encore une minorité mais qui
sont de plus en plus nombreuses mais il
est un peu dans la surenchère là jean
françois copé
il est dans c'est dans son tempérament
entier de dramatiser voilà alors
justement avec ses propositions chocs
on dit que jean françois copé et l'ump
vers la droite la question est posée
c'est la crise et sont non seulement de
la gauche mais aussi de certains ténors
de droite vous propose de regarder à ce
sujet de mathilde bel engin blanc à
faire du pain au chocolat et aujourd'hui
appellent à manifester contre l'exécutif
le concours précieux celui de la droite
décomplexée quitte à faire grincer
quelques dents au sein même de son parti
dernier en date de nos apparu qui
voulaient rester non alignés a pris
position pour françois fillon il à
cuisson l'adversaire de faire bouger le
centre de gravité du parti vers la
droite
si on veut maintenir gmp demain il faut
que le futur président de l'ump soit
capable de rassembler ses diversités
familles politiques qui composent l'une
à partir du moment où jean françois copé
se fait plus tôt le patron
l'une des composantes de l'ump et non
pas de l'ensemble de la famille
politique j'ai peur entre guillemets
pour l'avenir de l'ump
à deux semaines de l'élection interne
françois fillon est toujours en tête des
intentions de vote chez les
sympathisants ump mais selon les proches
de jean françois copé les adhérents eux
seraient naturellement marquer plus à
droite un sondage place d'ailleurs la
notion de la droite forte l'un des
courants les plus radicaux de l'ump en
tête des intentions de vote chez les
militants la droite forte c'est quoi
c'est pas une droite plus à droite que
les autres c'est une droite assume avec
fierté et sans complexe la révolution
sarkozyste et et donc les militants
souhaitent prolonger cette aventure
cette aventure collective humaine et ne
pas revenir à la droite d'avant à la
droite du siècle passé qui parfois avait
un peu honte d'être elle-même alors
l'ump est elle menacée d'éclatement où
c'est le spectre agité par les fonctions
de françois fillon qui mise tout sur le
candidat du rassemblement
à l'heure où jean louis borloo lance
l'offensive au centre anti roulis dit
lundi rester chez elle c'est de voir
ressurgir et a perdu f
on voit bien que du côté des
ils sont clairement des perspectives et
c'est bien pour ça que je fais choisir
entre filles parce qu'effectivement il
me semble que si jean françois copé
leurs portes demain nous nous avons
clairement le risque d'avoir les deux
tendances qui s'exprime dans deux partis
politiques différentes sur certains
points cependant les deux candidats
semblait avoir rapproché leurs points de
vue lors du débat jeudi dernier sur
france 2 françois fillon a rejoint son
rival sur la question du ni ni ni fn ni
ps en cas de duel électoral sans l'ump
nous a rejoint sur le plateau concert
s'admire on va reparler longue et des
vieilles querelles rpr udf de
l'éclatement possible de l'ump avec vous
bonsoir
redoutez vous donc que jean françois
copé sing and less et de mey président
de l'ump alors que vous soutenez
françois fillon et bien des places le
sont le centre de gravité de votre
formation politique vers la droite
c'est le vrai problème de l'ump c'est
que c'est une formidable machine le
premier tour est une très mauvaise
deuxième tour c'est à dire un parti qui
est isolé et qui ne parvient pas à
fédérer autour de lui et qui au
contraire même on l'a vu en 2004 on
l'avait en 2008 aux municipales on l'a
vu en 2010 aux régionales rassemble
contre lui des gens qui n'ont rien de
commun de l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche
si ce n'est de ne pas vouloir de l'ump
pourquoi je soutiens françois fillon
parce que je pense profondément qu'il a
une double caractéristique d'une part il
fédère toute l'ump
toute l'ump dans sa diversité et
d'autres pas il crée il oblige chacun à
prendre sa responsabilité à l'extérieur
de l'ump c'est à dire aller qui
préférez-vous infiné et je crois qu'avec
françois fillon nous serons gagnants
deuxième tome copé on va vers
l'éclatement de
tours vous seriez ans quand on ne va on
ne va pas vers l'éclatement de l'ump je
ne pense pas en tous les cas moi je
respecte les règles d'une élection jean
françois copé était lui sera notre
président mais en revanche nous serons
plus faible au deuxième tour parce que
jean françois et plus clivants vis-à-vis
du centre et paradoxalement vis-à-vis de
la droite qu'il réveille d'extrême
droite qu'il réveille et qu'il juste
titre qui le provoquent en quelques
sortes
et donc nous risquons de nous
recroqueviller ce qui serait évidemment
un échec
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'appartenir à un parti on voit de
lepénisation pour reprendre les propos
d'harlem désir
je vais parler de quelque chose qui peu
connu c'est que le même jour nous
voterons pour d'émotion et nous aurons
ainsi une photographie des convictions
de l'ump les membres de l'ump et d'un
côté on aura un président bons et de
l'autre nous aurons une sorte de des
mouvements tous les cas on aura une
sorte de record des tares la dta des
forces intellectuelles intérieur de
l'ump moi je suis exaspéré l'entente
membres de l'ump de voir ma formation
représentée par des expressions
solitaire qui sont parfois drôles
parfois passionnante parfois marginal
parfois excessive mais qui en tout état
de cause n'ont pas d'autre légitimité
que l'auto proclamation sa grâce au
mieux tous au parti socialiste par
exemple quand vous avez quand vous aviez
par exemple chevènement on savait qu'il
avait une grosse voix mais qui
représentait 5 ou 10% du ts coin finale
là lorsque l'on parle de l'ump nous
avons des gens qui s'expriment avec
talent ou avec la provocation que est-il
personne n'en sait rien grâce aux votes
des mouvements nous saurons si l'ump ce
que je pense profondément humaniste
libéral girondine européenne et les
gaullistes pour une part on verra ce que
pèse le gaullisme elle est très à droite
pour certains eh ben on verra ce que ça
représente vous on vous posera tout à
l'heure une question sur la motion
raffarin
centrale que vous soutenez mais revenons
sur cette campagne ces différences de
style entre les ans françois copé et
françois françois fillon c'est françois
fillon nous parler de rassemblement il
faut dit françois fillon ramener vers
l'ump ceux qui ont voté front national
et ceux qui ont voté à gauche pour
françois hollande mais il n'y aurait-il
pas davantage de réserves de voix pour
vous à l'extrême droite et l'extrême
droite c'est très hétérogène moi je
viens de l'extrême droite avant le
rappel en général bon c'était il ya 40
ans mais enfin bon puisqu'on me le
rappelle je puisse en parler c'est qu'il
y a à la fois un fond d'extrême droite
et il y a je dirais les inquiète de la
mondialisation je vois dans le dans
l'est industriel et ouvrier le vote
ouvrier lorsqu'il est front national et
c'est en général le premier ou le
deuxième vote ouvrier
c'est un vote de salariés français qui
ont peur de la mondialisation notre
devoir nous l'ump c'est de leur dire la
france est gagnante dans la
mondialisation parce que nous sommes
capables de vendre nos produits
à une seule condition c'est d'avoir des
règles de compétitivité qui soit
acceptable ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et encore moins avec les
mesures socialistes toujours possible
pour l'ump
j'ai signalé le fait que marine le pen
contrairement à son père ne je ne n'ai
pas jusqu'à présent des moindres est son
discours de provocation de type durafour
crématoire bon état elle l'a jamais fait
elle a été un petit peu maladroite sur
un sujet non enfin bon c'est un problème
pour l'ump d'ailleurs pour toutes les
autres partis politiques parce que quand
le front national se caricature il
s'isole lorsqu'il ne se caricature pas
il peut attraper à gauche ou à la droite
ou au centre des voix d'ailleurs s'il ya
je ne sais conciliation partielle dans
la circonscription de madame le pen en
définitive la décision n'a pas été prise
sur l'annulation non pas encore c'est un
humain hénin beaumont ce sera un cas
intéressant parce que le front national
prend à tout le monde mais est-ce que ça
arrête un interlocuteur possible ou pas
pour l'ump ça non mais maintenant ça
l'était au moins de même que j'ai jamais
dit
cet état l'interlocuteur passé j'ai dit
que c'était un partenaire plus dangereux
parce que techniquement et
sémantiquement plus habile il se nourrit
de quelque chose qui est durable
c'est la crainte des conséquences de la
mondialisation et la crainte d'une
société française dont les règles
traditionnelles de vie serait sans
contrôle appartement vous repris le mot
de partenaires aujourd'hui sans
partenaire plus dangereux c'est à un
acteur de la vie politique plus
dangereux nous nous disputons les mêmes
électeurs mais je vous rappelle que le
parti communiste et mélenchon les
disputes aussi jean marie le pen marine
le pen vous êtes gêné par certains
aspects de la campagne jean françois
copé qui fait la même analyse que vous
il faut on didier je pense simplement
qu'il a tort par exemple le racisme anti
blanc comment avez vous réagi à cette
question qui ont repris cette question
parce que ça a été un ramenant de 550 nm
les parlers dray et je dois dire
qu'après les législatives de 2012
plusieurs députés m'ont dit sur le
terrain nous avons été prise à partie
par des citoyens français
il y avait une intention de voter ou
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'intention de
voter mais qui nous agressaient en tant
que entre guillemets bullois c'est la
première fois que ça arrive citoyens
français qui vous disent oui vous les
veaux loi c'est à dire ça ne surprend
pas beaucoup parce que j'appartiens une
région la lorraine est une terre
d'immigration et je sais très bien qu
entre italiens et est lorrain ça a été
dans les années 20 dans les années 30
des expressions souvent musclé de part
et d'autre de part et d'autre les uns
est bon donc ciblé cela a toujours
existé
le dire est qu'ils scandaient le nom et
le en faire une affaire nationale
c'est dangereux parce que c'est une
réalité ce n'est pas la réalité
française
que dites-vous à guillaume pelletier que
nous avons vu également dans ce
reportage qui redoute ce matin encore
dans le figaro
la fin de la révolution culturelle issue
du sarkozysme guillaume pelletier et la
modestie d'abord de se faire élire sur
son bilan
on va rappeler c'est le leader de la
droite fort guillaume pelletier est un
garçon qui a de l'avenir qui est plutôt
brillant et il m'agace parce que de quel
droit par le tulle il avait et que la
sarkozie fait la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
et dans son sillage il y a des gens qui
était illuminée par le soleil radieux
mais la politique c'est d'apporter
quelque chose c'est d'apporter des
électeurs moi j'ai été gagné une
circonscription de gauche je les
apporter à l'udf
j'étais gagner une région de gauche je
les apporter à la majorité et je me suis
senti le droit de parler quand j'avais
réussi des combats électoraux
ce n'est pas encore le cas guillaume
pepy il a réussi à être remarquée par
par des amis de nicolas sarkozy tant
mieux pour lui ça ne suffit pas à en
faire une autorité politique
vous venez de le rappeler vous êtes un
ancien de l'udf est ce que vous craignez
avec la création de lui dès le retour de
la guerre entre l'ump ndi ne serait le
remède de la guerre pf c'est parce que
je crains ce que je crains c'est que nos
amis de l'idée y ait ce l'ump d'ailleurs
oublie simplement que dans ce
face-à-face rpr udf le remake est
impossible pourquoi est il impossible
parce que le front national existe et si
dans une saison mais ils étaient
marginales en 80 front national était
totalement marginal en 86 il existait
grâce à la proportionnelle mais en 88
qu'il n'a pas fait 10% des voix aux
législatives
le jour où le front national il ce jour
est arrivé
en 2012 on l'a vu où le front national
se maintient aux présidentielles avec
madame le pen et aux législatives dans
l'est que je connais en alsace enchanté
lent enfin si vous prenez l'est de la
france depuis le havre jusqu'à perpignan
tout ce qui est à l'est vous avez un
front national quitte à plus de 20%
donc ici
c'est une menace pour l'ump alors c'est
une menace pour la droite modérée et
pour le centre d'être absente du
deuxième tour l'un et l'autre s'il se
divise en croyant pouvoir rejouer le
faire le remake hd au rpr udf des sports
le débat il existe à l'intérieur de
l'ump moines mon seul regret je veux
dire c'est que l'ump n'est pas à temps
n'est pas organisé le débat avant de
telle sorte que l'ennui borloo soit à
l'intérieur et ce qui serait bien c'est
que borloo soient candidats aujourd'hui
à la présidence de l'ump
il n'a pas il a préféré voir son petit
truc à lui je crois qu'il a tort aux
élections je pense notamment aux
municipales lui de servir à reconquérir
à droite par exemple à des villes comme
un passé centristes comme toulouse même
peut-être pas rien la camp d'été vous
allez tout à fait raison je pense qu'il
y a une une territorialisation des
comportements politiques et cette
territorialisation est liée à l'histoire
même des territoires dans l'ouest
catholique
le front national ils seront peu et la
position parfois un peu autoritaire et
centralisatrice de l'ump n'est pas
acceptée donc il y a ou bien nous
évoluons et on regagnera ou bien lu dei
empochera en revanche crois qu'il y aura
du mal à faire comprendre dans l'est
industriel ou en région parisienne que
c'est autour de ces voies en revanche en
région parisienne vous avez dans les
milieux urbains
quand vous avez des csp + vous avez un
besoin de différenciation que l'ump
n'est pas capable de totalement absorbé
alors justement vous n'entendez la
perche borloo à paris c'est une option
possible pour que la droite regagne
paris
moi je veux je sais pas je suis à paris
je ne connais pas la vie politique
parisienne comme ils suffisamment pour
porter un jugement définitif je constate
simplement que législatives
nous avons une très mauvais résultats et
donc est ce que bordeaux pourrait plaire
aux csp + certains s'est passé à table
et en tout état de cause au à paris le
front national fn
ce qui fait qu'à paris la possibilité de
choisir et plus grande qu'ailleurs parce
que l'ump pourrait quand même se ranger
derrière un candidat il est
comme jean louis borloo apparaît comme
le meilleur candidat
ici pas de tour et les deux tours ne
sont dangereux que si le front national
vous écarte du deuxième tour comme
justin a été écarté du deuxième tour
donné deux fils il n'y a pas ce risque
la comparaison la stimulation pour le
libéral que je suis la stimulation la
comparaison me gêne pas dernière
question cette dernière question sur les
courants l'émotion le vote des motions
qui est l'autre enjeu du congrès d'une
idée du 18 novembre
vous soutenez la motion raffarin avec
des gens qui viennent de tout horizon
est ce que cette motion justement
central voire centriste peut contenir
une influence de deluz délits sur les
militants et les sympathisants de l'ump
je souhaite profondément je souhaite
profondément que les chats le message
européen
le message libéral le message girondins
le message de traditions sociales soient
forts à l'ump pour que mes amis d'ulysse
honte aux emmy pour dire la vérité se
disent bah tiens après tout on a notre
place à l'ump dans cette famille là
merci sarkozy gérard longuet a parlé
maintenant du sénat puisque l'ambiance
politique nationale ce ressenti au
niveau de la haute assemblée aux
difficultés du gouvernement s'ajoute ici
des problèmes de majorité sur certains
textes
il faut dire que la gauche n'a que 6
voix d'avancé sur la droite et du coup
certains notamment à l'ump commencent à
rêver d'une alternance en 2014 regardait
ça va partage sandra faire car
officiellement tout va bien mais hors
caméra certains socialistes se disent
inquiets la majorité est instable mise à
mal sur plusieurs textes traités
européens loi sur l'énergie le logement
et bientôt le budget les couacs se
multiplient et les sondages sont au plus
bas
pas facile tous les jours pour la gauche
je trouve ça totalement excessifs
totalement non fondées bon les médias
font leur travail et sont volontiers
critique mais cela n'en portent pas la
réalité de l'action gouvernementale
il faut laisser du temps au temps comme
on disait
mais en politique le temps s'accélère à
l'ump on pense déjà aux municipales de
2014 et des répercussions que ces
élections intermédiaires pourraient
avoir sur les sénatoriales et la gauche
qui souffrent c'est une aubaine pour
l'opposition qui se voit déjà rencontré
rire le sénat dans deux ans pour
préparer l'alternance
on récupère 20 villes et l'affairé
réglée mais c'est ce qui va se passer
dans 18 mois va récupérer les villes on
a beau dire on doit les récupérer c'est
pas uniquement taille dans marseille il
ya tout le reste des villes moyennes et
après on aura suffisamment le plan
directeur pour apprendre le sénat ce qui
sera un hymne à présidentielle une
marque importante dollar compte est déjà
en embuscade au groupe ump
les grandes manoeuvres commencent on
parle même d'un match retour entre
gérard larcher l'ancien président du
sénat et jean pierre raffarin candidat
malheureux à la présidence en 2008 le
sénateur des yvelines a fait de la
reconquête du sénat une priorité le
discours est bien rodé
comme s'il était déjà en campagne par
notre rôle d'opposant déterminé mais
aussi constructif d'essayer de remettre
en route
cette machine france qui a totalement
grippé depuis quatre mois deuxième des
choses
assumer notre devoir d'opposants et puis
préparer préparer l'alternance se les
soient politiques
c'est le choix politique que je conduis
pour l'ump à la présidence de l'ump
justement gérard larcher soutien à
françois fillon
alors que jean pierre raffarin s'est
rangé lui du côté de jean-françois copé
l'unité du groupe sénatorial ump risque
bien aussi de connaître quelques
difficultés
bonsoir monsieur longuet je vais parler
bien sûr dans un instant de l'ump mais
évidemment quand même parlé aussi de
l'actuelle majorité il ya eu pas mal de
couacs en série ces derniers temps je
parle du texte notamment sur le logement
le texte sur l'énergie
est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui au
président du sénat d'intervenir de taper
un petit peu du poing sur la table
on met de l'ordre de taper du poing non
de faire son boulot de président du
sénat alors qu'il appartient la majorité
traditionnellement les présidents de
deux chambres assemblée nationale et
sénat se retrouve avec le président de
la république le premier ministre pour
gérer l'ordre du jour parlementaire et
avec un petit peu d'expérience
ce couac sur la loi sur l'urbanisme
aurait été moins vite et logement et
puis de la même façon ne pas présenter
des textes dont on sait qu'ils n'ont pas
de majorité sont voilà sauf si on
cherche la rupture dans son propre camp
on dit que président du snel n'est pas
assez présent ne fait pas assez son
travail
je ne sais pas comment fonctionne le
système politique
socialiste mais manifestement il
fonctionne mal alors cela pose aussi
peut-être un problème sur la crédibilité
de la haute assemblée dont vous n'avez
pas l'impression que il ya un petit peu
de crédibilité en ce moment ça c'est une
autre affaire de plus long terme je
pense que le recrutement du sénat a
considérablement évolué notamment avec
la proportionnelle dans les grands
départements
d'un côté c'est une respiration et des
personnalités plus plus originales et de
l'autre côté nous n'avons plus les abris
les femmes politiques
les hommes politiques d'expérience je
rappelle que les hommes c'est un terme
générique comporte les femmes un homme
sur deux est une femme nouvellement ça
du bon en apparence mais je dire salut
mon apparence parce qu'il ya une verdeur
une fraîcheur dans l'expression
superficialité dans les prises de
position et de temps en temps on a
l'impression que donne nos collègues en
réinvente le sucre et sur les effectifs
depuis très longtemps
ils sont un peu trop jeunes un peu trop
vers oui mais ce qui pose problème
surtout en ce moment je pense au plf et
je pense aux textes les français sont
plutôt les communistes qui le sont
implantés depuis que longue date que les
verts au sénat oui mais il ne trouve pas
en face d'eux les autorités
intellectuelles dans leur camp à gauche
qui leur permettrait de revenir sur une
position solide
au fond qu'est le fond du problème c'est
exactement la gauche il est visé par ce
que les verts ont décidé faire du
nucléaire
leur cheval de bataille pour en priver
la france et les communistes par
tradition et je la respecte parce que
c'est aussi la mienne souhaite défendre
le nucléaire
donc vous avez une rupture politique à
l'intérieur de la gauche est elle
s'exprime publiquement alors on l'a vu
cette rupture également sur le texte sur
l'énergie peut-être sur le post boîte
finances comme on disait cette
opposition finalement c'est pas vous ce
sont les communistes ils font votre
boulot c'est plus exactement il n'y a
pas de majorité
il n'y a pas de majorité politique c'est
à dire d une râpe alicia seulement
mais ça ça c'est des sièges politique
mais sur le fond c'est à dire sur un
vouloir agir ensemble
il n'y a pas de majorité gouvernementale
au sénat il y en a une à l'assemblée n'a
pas de mettre d'accord de gouvernement
et l'accord de gouvernement entre les
échos entre les écolos et le ps est
quand même extraordinairement curieux
parce que quand vous avez un accord de
gouvernement avec des parlementaires
verts qui ne veut pas c'était quand même
l'alpha et l'oméga de la politique
gouvernementale
la règle d'or c'est quand même assez
surprenant c'est aussi assez étrange
quand même devant les communistes les
l'ump être ensemble sur ce morceau
position la taxe sur le nucléaire nous
avons toujours été du même avis pour des
raisons de là quand même non pas du tout
les nous nous le faisons par intérêt
national le parti communiste le fait par
intérêt d'entreprise
mais il se trouve que l'entreprise d'edf
avait les intérêts la norme française
par la droite un petit peu aussi pas
mystère aussi vous voulez récupérer le
sénat en 2014
mais visiblement il va y avoir aussi un
problème car la moitié des sénateurs ump
pour être renouvelé est ce que c'est un
candidat un handicap pour vous
c'est en tous les cas une responsabilité
est en effet un risque mais c'est la
règle du jeu est ce que l'hypothèse
d'alternance à nouveau et crédible
oui à tarzy l'écart est faible et comme
le disait pierre charon puisque vous le
souhaitiez 20 villes qui bascule ça
suffirait j'ai pas la carte électorale
en tête comme il peut la voir ou comme
jean claude gaudin à mes crises mais
j'ai aucune raison de penser qu'ils se
trompent ripoll aussi avoir un
changement de mode de scrutin ça a été
évoqué par un français on peut tout ça
risque de vous indiquer p on peut tout
ne leur a pas vraiment l'expérience
prouve que les changements de mode de
scrutin c'est essayer c'est le râteau du
jardinier vos marques et marchés sur les
dents et nous prenez le mans dans la
figure enfin on l'a vu dans le sujet ça
pourrait aussi le match retour entre
jean-pierre raffarin et gérard larcher
vous êtes pour qui vous votez pour le
meilleur quoi qu'il a
c'est à dire est-ce qu'on peut aller un
petit peu plus haut non non c'est pas
une guerre si vous voulez il ya des
postes il ya des rivalités de personnes
philibert à je suis pour la libre
compétition
je suis un ami de jean pierre raffarin
dominique senard si je respecte le
travail de gérard larcher et jusqu'ici
troisièmement venu il ya sûrement un
troisième mineur il peut y avoir une
femme un jeune vous inscrivez un petit
peu de ce paysage non moi j'aimerais
avoir les responsabilités plus que j'en
ai aujourd'hui ne serait ce que j'en ai
j'en ai eues j'étais très content de les
avoir et puis vous avez été ministre
il ya beaucoup de responsabilités au
sénat qui sont passionnantes et que nous
allons nous avons des responsabilités
tournante
moi je suis très parlementaire jetterait
parlementaire je suis candidat a exercé
les responsabilités parlementaires c'est
à dire apprendre un dossier d'en prendre
un dossier est à l'étude y est à fond et
à faire partager ma conviction par mes
collègues de ma majorité ou de
l'opposition la création d'une
commission
voilà tous étiez tout ce qui est le
débat intellectuel dans laquelle je peux
m'engager pour convaincre me plaît parce
que d'abord était le verbe d'abord les
idées et les places sujet cette foutue
dans la vie politique et donc et grâce à
nicolas sarkozy j'ai eu le plus beau
ministère qui soit donc je ne demande
rien en terme de statut et beaucoup en
termes de responsabilité intellectuelle
rappelle que vous avez été ministre de
la défense donc questions à l'ancien
ministre la défense ait eu des bugs
informatiques en syrie qui affecte
depuis plus d'un an le versement
notamment des salaires des militaires
votre successeur jean yves le drian a
décidé de prendre le dossier en main on
peut se demander pourquoi est ce que
vous n'avez pas
avant parce qu'en réalité il y a des
difficultés elles sont extrêmement
marginal est liée à la complexité même
du statut du militaire puisque les
militaires ont à la fois une seule
principale et des indemnités qui varient
en fonction de leur engagement en
campagne et il faut identifier cela nous
avons engagé un effort informatiques
peuvent pas le ministre qui l'a fait
mais l'administration l'a fait et je
considère qu'à 98 5%
l'administration a rempli son contrat et
s'il me fait le drian parvient à mettre
fin les excès j'en suis le premier
heureux pour les militaires
alors évidemment on va le rappeler les
militaires ont un droit de réserve ils
n'ont pas droit de s'exprimer ce sont
alors ses 12 entre autres qui se sont
exprimés détrompez vous il y à une
représentation militaire et un conseil
supérieur la fonction publique militaire
qui est extra niveau lycée se sont
exprimés et qui s'expriment et qui a
parfaitement droite c est vous les
allemands nous avons évoqué ce problème
nous allons y avait aussi fait from sur
la carte notamment sur la défense des
pommes de base etc
attention tout à 4 été lancé en 2009 il
ya la loi de programmation 2008 2015
elle évolue par le parlement et les
militaires doivent l'appliquer et j'ai
défendu cette la mise en oeuvre de cet
texte et je crois avoir convaincu mes
interlocuteurs en revanche il peut y
avoir d'aidé dans le fonctionnent dans
la mise en oeuvre pratique d'une réforme
des difficultés ministry ces deux
réformes conduites d'une façon énergique
n'en a pas le temps d'attendre parce que
tout cela c'est des sommes considérables
et ce sont surtout des carrières qui ont
besoin d'avoir des certitudes
donc je pense que la réforme est bonne
et je pense qu'il y a à l'intérieur de
l'armée à travers les conseils de
d'armes et les conseils et le conseil
supérieur le moyen du dialogue
nous n'avons pas besoin de manifester
parce que alarmé s'attelle veut
surprendre mais on se parle beaucoup en
interne
vous avez déjà répondu tout à l'heure
mais je vais essayer de prendre la
question différemment c'est une question
de pierre ory via l'application timide
chèque de notre partenaire orange c'est
sur l'attitude de ces maires frondeurs
qui nous célèbrerons pas les mariages
pour tous est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ces mères je soutiens françois
fillon françois fillon a dit qu'il était
républicain et qu'il appliquait la loi
il y a des problèmes de conscience qui
ont été reconnus aux médecins des
problèmes de confiance ya d'autres
professions qui ont le droit d'avoir des
des cas de conscience et qui les exonère
de mettre en oeuvre telle ou telle
mesure
après tout les maires peuvent demander à
bénéficier eux aussi la droite que de
conscience droit-fil journalistes on
monte un oui mais les nerfs sont des
élus les maires sont désolés de voir
annette ils sont élus mais pas
nécessairement pour n'importe quoi
très bien merci michael szames s merci
gérard longuet d'avoir été un autre
invité ce soir bonne phares et à tous
sur l'antenne de public sénat mardi